hommage un autre collègue de la DGFiP
monsieur Ludovic Montiel je vous demande
de bien vouloir observer une minute de
silence
il a ce drame qui intervient et ça dans
un climat de tension et la l'État a sa
part de responsabilité dans le cas où
les Français vivent de plus en plus mal
ce qui est compliqué c'est qu'on peut
pas se projeter pourquoi à l'heure
actuelle on a un coût d'énergie qui
député on ne sait pas ce que ça
deviendra en 2023 ou 2024
faire le dos rond pendant une année
peut-être amortisseur et puis le fenêtre
de filet on a les deux mais en fait
l'amortisseur permet de d'atténuer un
peu le prix mais en fait de 65 euros
bien plus même en fait le prix que vous
avez été proposé c'était 2068 euros
c'était délirant
et on a vraiment besoin de passer de 65
à 180 je pense je n'ai jamais vu mon
pays aussi fracturé qu'aujourd'hui
depuis des années le politique y compris
parfois Emmanuel Macron a pris soin pour
des raisons souvent tactiques de posture
politique de dresser les uns contre les
autres
je fais des choix aujourd'hui mais
cornéliens est-ce qu'il faut arrête mon
école de musique est-ce que ma cantine
je vais la passer en Sodexo à autre
chose c'est pas possible et les gens ne
comprennent pas parce qu'ils perdent
leurs impôts et c'est pas une solution
d'augmenter la taxe de 50 %, je pourrais
le faire mais on paye déjà nettement
assez d'impôts moi quand je suis arrivé
au ministère du Budget j'ai découvert
qu'il y avait un système absolument
délirant appelé loyers capitalisé qui
avait été mis en place de manière
dérogatoire à l'époque de François
Hollande négociait avec Anne Hidalgo sur
le terrain on est un peu le petit ball
de la société c'est à dire que quand les
gens vont pas bien quand ils ont quelque
chose à demander ils sont relativement
exigeants c'est tout de suite au maire
que l'adresse se fait et quand il y a
une expression de violence c'est à ceux
qui incarnent l'autorité donc ou l'état
et c'est qui est sur le terrain le plus
proche des citoyens sont les mers la
réalité c'est qu'il y a plus d'un
milliard d'euros désormais d'endettement
plus pour la ville de Paris lié à ce
système honnêtement c'est sa relève du
Ponzi de nouveaux éléments accablant
dans l'affaire Adrien 4 mains ce député
de très médiatique de la France
insoumise qui a avoué avoir gifler son
épouse qui avait suscité souvenez-vous
une vie polémique et bien cette dernière
qui avait porté plainte dénonce
aujourd'hui des colères et des violences
physiques et morales répétées depuis
plusieurs années
elle fait état de violences récurrentes
et donc sa parole doit être respectée et
aujourd'hui je pense que Adrien catenens
ne peut pas revenir à l'Assemblée nous
au groupe
il me semble nous avons pris une
position ferme pour dire qu'il fallait
qu'il se mette en retrait du groupe et
je ne vois pas pourquoi on changerait
cette position on ne peut pas faire
comme si ça n'existait pas et donc c'est
une catin en tant que femme doit être
entendu respecter et la fille doit
entendre doit entendre ses paroles la
seule décision qui à mon avis est juste
et justifiée quand on a quand on est à
parti politique et qu'on est face ainsi
en quelque sorte à une brebis galluse
qui est de l'exclure du groupe la France
insoumise devrait exclure Adrien catenas
du groupe il lui est impossible de
revenir à l'Assemblée nationale ni pour
à ce stade je ne vois pas comment il
peut revenir mais la seule manière de ne
pas y revenir définitivement c'est de
prendre une décision beaucoup plus forte
politiquement cette démissionner on peut
pas être entre deux eaux on peut pas
être un fantôme à l'Assemblée nationale
mais il y a estimothy ont été conçus en
1992 François Mitterrand était encore
président et l'ancêtre d'Internet
s'appelait le Minitel il y a aujourd'hui
et malheureusement vous en êtes informé
presque autant que nous un divorce
extrêmement tendu extrêmement compliqué
dans lequel les velléités les demandes
financières ne sont pas satisfaites ou
la garde de l'enfant est un sujet et
c'est un secret pour personne que
parfois des divorces sont des moments
extrêmement tendus extrêmement
compliqués qui amène à des situations
extrêmement complexes l'idée est
immotise on est le 31 octobre dernier en
1992 alors embryon ils ont été congelés
par un couple dans son parcours de
fécondation in vitro en 2007 le couple a
décidé de les donner pour offrir la
possibilité à d'autres parents de les
accueillir